hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video today is
Monday January 23rd 2023
and
the overflows was uh quite interesting
today I mean it's in my opinion it was
pretty uh pretty easy to read in the
sense of you know remember Friday right
we had that nice rally uh pretty much
from about 12 until the close and then
overnight we just sort of went sideways
you know basically trading during the
Asian hours between about uh you know
39.80 and you know 39.87 we did pop up
during the European session got all the
way up to here at that was about 95.
um we did make uh get down to 80 and a
quarter and then you know just around
seven just after seven we traded all up
to four thousand and then came off then
cash opened and I don't want to say we
sold off when cash opened because we
moved on about six points or something I
don't know what was that actually
um this is a move from uh cashier 98
down to 86 actually so that was
um about a 12 point move then we just
took off
for the rest of the morning we did have
this deep pullback uh late about you
know just before one o'clock until about
two o'clock pulled back about 35 37
points and um you know we gained some of
that back but what I want to talk about
is you know just sort of to follow up
some of the in my opinion some of the
more easier things of the order flow now
what was interesting is when we traded
up to 4 000 okay that was around seven
actually after 720 okay we were going up
making these highs uh these get the
crosshairs up here you know we traded 35
up there
and the volume going up into those highs
you know nothing special now granted you
know it's Monday morning cash hasn't
opened up yet
um you know I know some people like to
sort of
um
disregard you know the the pre-market if
you will the overnight session and the
pre-market but you can't right you still
got to pay attention to the volumes
because sometimes you're going to see
something in the volume that you know
can be uh
useful later in the day so we traded up
there we hit the four thousand which is
straight at 35 nothing special right
it's kind of light actually I was maybe
expecting a couple hundred contracts to
to sort of stop if we're going to stop
up there
um and reverse but you know just sort of
came up there like pretty nonchalant
like it was nothing 35 and came off okay
it's all in the back of my mind I'm
thinking oh there's four thousand
nobody's really up there really
defending it I mean did we come off you
know we trade 4 000 and then you know we
trade down to what you know 91
92 nothing special
um then you know we're getting ready for
the Cash open like I said we had this I
don't call this a sell-off I mean it's
two bars cash opened up and we sold off
you know the high as 98 and a quarter
cash opened up around 96 and a half
rallied up just under two points and
then it sold down to you know 86 so you
know about a 12 point move then it just
starts going sideways now 4 000 are high
of the day is just right up here not too
far off for about 13 points off because
you know we're looking around 87 here
and it starts going sideways
but even though it's going sideways it's
starting to move a little bit higher and
you can sort of get some I don't see
some inklings in the Delta but if you're
watching the Delta you know they were
kind of small here but then they start
growing okay I mean earlier once cash
opened we got a lot of back and forth
activity red bars green Two Reds green
red green red so it's kind of
alternating now we start rallying here
okay we got you know positive Delta 45
kind of small positive 79 positive 126
then 597 673.
okay so you know cash is open we spent
10 minutes
um sort of balancing you know getting
letting the orders work through the
order book you know all these cash open
orders you know view app over the first
five minutes Etc that um you know a lot
of these funds do and then we start
coming back up to 4 000. now remember
earlier we traded 4 000 around 720 and
you know pretty nonchalant 721 we hit
that High
um you know there's 35 contracts there
and even going up there wasn't a lot of
necessary of liquidity up there I mean
you see the 131 you know the 52. so
you know once we start coming back up
there I'm thinking hey you know what
maybe we can clear that pretty easy and
we do okay and on the way up a nice
little stacked imbalance here take out
this high in this bar and we've got you
know I've been talking about this last
week that abandoned value area okay now
you don't know it's going to be
abandoned until this next part closes
and it's just right there 39 basically
39.99 and a quarter down to 97.
nice bar up you got one two three four
five six binding balances
very nice right as you're taking out the
high you like to see that momentum pick
up and one of the signs you're going to
be seen in momentum is buying imbalances
okay then boom they got the high here
another one two three buying imbalances
now notice these are not stacked on each
other they're sort of spread out you got
another abandoned value area
okay
that's good now we start seeing some
signs of weakness some selling coming in
okay I mean we're training up here at 12
we got it in Balance come back up here
we got another imbalance at 12 and a
half
Market doesn't really come off pulls
back down to what nine
finally after this bar it pulls back
down to o5 so I know I got one balance
two in Balance now I've got a new
imbalance new imbalance here at uh 14
and a half okay you know just having
those two divergences
okay I said imbalance I meant Divergence
you got Divergence Divergence Divergence
okay these two failed
came back up here you got another
Divergence that's
that you gotta watch okay there's a
couple ways you could play you know if
you want to group these two and say well
this is just really one Divergence over
these two bars
okay you got Divergence here
and again what kind of pullback do you
have here not much
um
from 12 and a half down to five and a
quarter okay start coming off again okay
you have this
low of this move right here at five and
a quarter we sort of trade back down
towards that area sort of test it
come back up get within a point a tick
rather of this high in this bar and then
it's just like you could just sort of
sense it at this point now we've got a
new Divergence up here
so you've got you know you'll call these
two one another one so one two three
divergences now this one is a ratio
the red color number on top is a bearish
ratio and a Divergence okay to me that's
an automatic trade I like it
when you get a bearish ratio on a bar
with a Divergence
get short
well it just goes sideways on me
where's my stop just up here at 18.
now
this is the problem sometimes right when
you're trading ratios and divergences if
you've had a few ratios or sorry a few
divergences that that have failed and
the third one is the ratio and
Divergence
and you get short I mean you still got
to take the short you're not going to
handicap well you know I'm not going to
take it because I got that I mean you
could but you still got to take it
but also you got to be able to recognize
that you know I was talking about this a
lot last week identifying a flow driven
Market a market that is
um you know being driven by sort of
outside forces not outside in the sense
of you know people not involved in the
market but you know those longer term
traders that just sort of sit on the
sidelines you know they get in
put their position on and then they just
sit and wait and wait and wait and it
sort of feels like now they're starting
to come into this Market because you've
already had one Divergence that failed
another Divergence and potentially
another one because you don't really
sell off from this this is a in my book
this is a very bearish signal so I'm
looking for a sell-off
and it's proceeds to go lower by one two
three ticks okay then it comes up here
to new High this is where your stop is
if you're short here this is where your
new entry is to get long
and at you know you could be getting
long at 18 and a quarter 18 and a half
because now if it starts taking out
these highs you're in a different Market
condition you're in a market condition
that is being driven by long-term
Traders other time frame Traders people
that buy and hold they buy and sit right
they don't sit there and watch the
intraday swings so you got plenty of
opportunity to be getting in here
somewhere anywhere coming in around the
19 area right that 19 should be the
worst case scenario but you should be
able to get in you know 18 and a half
oh it's 18 and a quarter but you know at
least 18 and a half 19 worst case
and starts trading back up right new
highs new highs new highs now what was
interesting when you start moving up to
these new highs is
you're seeing
one you're seeing signs of aggressive
buying I mean you were seeing these the
aggressive buying earlier with all these
majority of buying imbalances as you're
seeing here buying one two three four
five here one two three here one two
three four
one one two three four right as you're
making new highs you have that strong
aggressive buying coming in but more
importantly what else do you have
look at this green bar green bar
negative Deltas so you know there's some
support coming in the market you can
also see it you know on these bars going
up you can see the 500 on the bid here
the 600 on the bid here the 500 on the
bid as we're going up here I mean look
at this
um
you know 960 on the bid here okay and it
just keeps going up so I mean ideally
you should have been long worst case
scenario around the 19 area and another
Divergence it fails another Divergence
it fails
every five ten minutes we're getting a
Divergence what's the Divergence on a
rallying Market is it's a new or equal
high with negative Delta negative Delta
signifies that there's aggressive
selling in the market
so you've got
the new high you've got that aggressive
selling coming in and the market just
keeps on trucking keeps on going right
back up to new highs
again you should have been long in that
19-ish area
right and it pulls back a little bit
pulls back down to 20 and then again
higher highs look at all these
imbalances one two three four even here
at one two one two
right and you can see this Market is is
going up
all right moving higher on negative
Delta and it was this I watched some
videos some kid I'm dropping Alpha on
you I'm dropping Alpha the kid would
always say I'm dropping Alpha here
um I was just laughing but um you know
put it together okay you're going higher
on negative Delta well that's a sign of
support coming into the market you know
to stop this move from going any lower
there's buyers willing to absorb
whatever aggressive selling is coming in
and we just keep higher more buying
imbalances one two three four
then here it really pops up from you
know the 31 area you got one two three
four five imbalances another five
imbalances six imbalances in this bar
again another abandoned value area right
here
stacked in Balance here right and it
just keeps going up I was literally
talking about these almost every single
day last week looking for those failed
divergences looking for these
um abandoned value areas now if you want
to even take it a step further
okay I mean you know we spent a lot of
time on that you should understand what
you're looking at now in terms of
imbalances and and
you know bars with multiple imbalances
abandoned value areas divergences that
are that are failing left and right now
you could start to use other tools
things like thin prints in a bar Okay so
let me just uh highlight those two
really quick so
T then where are you here right then
prints okay I'll enable it now
you could set a maximum volume okay but
I'll just keep it at zero
okay and I'm gonna draw it until tested
so anytime there's a zero
inside the range of a bar not including
the top price or the bottom price inside
the body of the bar
and it hasn't been retested in the next
bar that's a sign of momentum it's a
sign of a market that's moving pretty
fast so
what because really what's happening is
when you have a zero and it's left in in
the market like that
there's no counter trade there's nobody
came down and hit the bid against it
right because the Market's moving fast
someone lifted the offer so on a market
moving up what you're going to be
looking for is on the bid side you're
gonna be looking for the zero print just
as if a market is moving down
you'll be looking for on the offer side
the zero print so perfect example here
in this bar
okay and this is the bar you should have
been getting long off you got the zero
right here
right because as you know the Market's
getting bid up
it reaches that point where it just
jumps on you very little counter trait
someone just got aggressive and swept
through the market you can see they
traded 12 they traded 97 here but here
is zero and it just left it there and
when you see that just sort of abandoned
you know this Market has
momentum to it okay and you can see it
as as the Market's going up right you
just see these zeros
being left behind here's another two
here
all right
see if there's anything on that way down
if there's any zeros on the way down
yeah there was one here
a couple here as we go back up you know
they make great targets by the way I
mean I'll do another video on that
um
you know there's one there
again look how it just came look how
these two here came right back to the
tick here and I blew through it you know
it's one of those things where if you
wanted to have something we could
literally have a one tick stop or two
tick stop look at something like zero
prints yeah you get stopped out here you
get stopped out here but you buy it
right to the tick here look at this you
buy it right to the tick here
okay
so you know this the Market's under
momentum now let's take a look real
quick at this sell-off okay because the
sell-off started here around 1250 right
before one o'clock and started moving
down and you know people say well whoa
whoa It's So Clear in there well
obviously I could see this bar here I
have the Prominent Point of controls
turned off this is a bearish problem
with point of control though
um
right up here at the just that on the
bar with the high of the day but you see
all the strong negative Delta in here
now as this Market is going sideways you
do have this the strong negative Delta
so it's kind of mixed you know you got
these small green candles and again you
know we had literally rallied you know
we were all quite strong you know and
remember we're Trading you know 30 you
know on cash open 39.90 now we're
trading 40 56 so you know over 60 point
move
at some point
Mark is going to get show some signs of
weakness you just don't know right if
it's going to show it at 40 at 40 40 at
40 50. you know or 40 55 or 40 56 where
it finally did start to show it because
if you're trying to
get short earlier at some of these highs
you know you're just getting your head
handed to you basically I mean there was
this pullback here
um
you know at 10 20 where we had a little
you know kind of a decent pullback
um and took a while to get back up to
these highs
but finally you know we start selling
off selling off and you can just sort of
see the shift by looking at the
imbalances in the bars one two three
four selling of balances one two three
four five sauna balances one two three
four five six selling imbalances so
you're seeing
um people getting aggressive up here
right it just people you know we just
remember we had about a 60 point rally
and then it starts showing some signs of
weakness I think that was people coming
in there and being aggressive just get
me out taking their profits I'm not
saying that everybody was buying it
around 39.90 but you know on that move
up from you know 40 10 40 20 40 30 40
all the way up to this 56 50 40 56 area
40 50 Area it's a good sign to you know
books and profits if you're along from
earlier
and it just sort of drifts sideways you
know more selling comes in here a little
bit later now we did again you can see
the zero prints the zero prints all
right you can see this one this one from
way earlier came back
to it it's got about a point through it
and then bounce back up again more zero
Prints but anyway
um you know we did catch a I don't say
catch a rally here but again on this
move back up
okay you have the abandoned value area
here thinking maybe it's going to go
down and it just reverses right here and
boom boom boom marches straight back up
so again you know put it together you
know again you don't have to get so
fancy on your trading just keep it
simple look at the value areas this
Market moving away from value is it
abandoning you know recognized value
areas
or is it coming back in and trading
around those areas and secondly you know
understanding what type of Market we're
in right if obviously if we're trending
you know it's going to be a flow driven
market and if it is you know signs are
going to be showing in the order flow
right you're going to see selling coming
in that is just one getting absorbed and
the market keeps going up
and obviously which way is the imbalance
is leaning towards now you know that's
just a simple eyeball check okay yeah I
can see I got one bar here I got two
another bar I got three another bar I
got three okay yeah I got aggressive
buying coming in uh I'm gonna be skewed
to the upside preferably so anyway guys
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and
I'll catch you on the next video bye bye